and on the point of this vaccine by the
way a lot of people don't want to get it
a lot of people don't want to get and i
think they have perfectly good reason
not to and
the white house despite bragging about
how so everyone's getting it and it's
we're
almost at 70 80 90 they clearly are not
hitting those numbers because
the white house and the ruling class
are enlisting pop culture figures to try
to get young people
to get vaccinated including olivia
rodrigo
someone i had never heard of until
yesterday who showed up to the white
house press briefing
to get your kids vaccinated i have a
special guest with me today
uh joining us in the briefing room is
actress and multi-platinum recording
singer-songwriter olivia rodrigo who
traversed red lights and stop times to
see us
if you know her music you'll get that
dad jokes there um
thing and we just want to thank you for
using your platform
and your voice for elevating the
important issue of young people getting
vaccinated she's here today to meet with
the president and dr fauci
later this afternoon but she agreed to
come say a quick hello to all of you
first with that i'll turn it over to you
olivia hi
um first i want to say i am beyond
honored and humbled to be here today to
help spread the message
about the importance of youth
vaccination
i'm in awe of the work president biden
and dr fauci have done
and was happy to help lend my support to
this important initiative
all right olivia rodrigo says it's
important for kids to get the vex
i guess i guess it's true because you
see we've got to follow the science
we've got to listen to the experts and
that means that when a
a parent musician that i've never heard
of tells you to do it then you do it
right that's
that's she's the expert she's they they
are the experts
the the ruling elite not just the
scientists but
the people in big business the people in
higher education the people
and the media the people they're they're
all the experts right cnn it's the
expert
pop singers they're the experts too this
sort of thing
used to work a lot better i get i get
why biden is doing this because biden is
100 years old
and he he was coming up in politics
during a time
when there was more of a common culture
so if you could get
the big movie star to come out and
support your political cause that was a
really big deal
if you could get the big pop singer to
come out that was a really big deal
what has changed though is that the the
culture has fractured
part of this was cultural because of the
cultural revolutionaries of the 60s
broke up our common culture
so part of this is the chickens coming
home to roost for the left part of this
is technological
there are no longer just three tv
networks it's a zillion tv networks none
of which
anybody watches a lot of internet
channels a lot of podcasts so
that's broken up to
because of that practical aspect i
suspect this is not going to have a
great effect i mean
we talk about how difficult the
political situation is right now on this
show
but a glimmer of hope here is that
the left has is dealing with this
double-edged sword
they upended the common culture during
the 1960s and 70s and they broke the
political consensus and they made
everything political
so now who washes the dishes is
political your running shoes are
political your chicken sandwiches
are political and everything is kind of
divisive
and everything makes a political
statement okay but
the flip side of that is that now that
they're trying to settle that
that culture back down along their own
standards people are still pretty
divided up there's still a lot of
niche audiences out there and i just
don't think people
are buying i don't think olivia rodrigo
is going to
convince people to take an experimental
drug uh
just because of the strength of her
records or whatever she sells
yo hey you stop right there before you
click don't click
you got to ring the bell you got to
subscribe then you will hopefully get
the notifications though sometimes big
tech doesn't want
our followers to get the notifications
you can watch this whole episode it's
called save us floridaman
uh you can also get it on apple podcast
spotify google play stitcher myspace
xanga live journal aol instant messenger
you can also order my book speechless
controlling words controlling minds
thank you to everyone who made it a
number one
national bestseller we really appreciate
that we really appreciate the new york
times too for snubbing us and
uh continuing to sell a lot of books for
us we really really appreciate that
thank you to all of you have read leave
a comment we'll see you next time
[Music]
you